[Music]
love death and robots has finally
dropped on Netflix and the anthology
series features many unique animations
that really showcase the benefits of the
platform to celebrate the release I
decided to break down the ending of the
premiere episode from the series and
give my thoughts on the entire show as a
whole this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't seen any of the episodes
yeah then I highly recommend that you
turn off now with that out the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I explain it so you don't have to
episode one titled Sony's edge is set in
a futuristic London that has seen the
industrial areas of the city rise in
prominence whilst the slums have slowly
fallen into decay and ruin and this
episode is really about the underclass
fighting against the rich we follow a
group known as the Predators that
compete in fighting tournaments with
mutated animals called beasts before a
said tournament sunny is approached by a
rich man named bigger who attempts to
bribe her into taking her die before she
rejects his offer which is when we learn
that sunny is actually fighting for
revenge we learn that the scars on her
face were caused by a group of men that
raped her and she's attempting to track
them down an exact upon them the same
pain that they delta her so he enters
the arena to fight with her beast named
carnivore and using a psychic link she
takes control of it and has a face off
against one named horrible Raptor it's
pretty safe to say that the CGI is
absolutely phenomenal and watching the
beasts go head-to-head is outstanding
whilst Oviraptor is larger in stature
and similar to something like doomsday
from the DC Universe carnivore has speed
and agility as well as some amazing iron
spider like legs that it uses to slice
its opponent to ribbons before ripping
off its arm
it's not over yet though and Torvill
Raptor is packing a blade beneath its
skin that it uses to slice carnivore
with before the former cuts into the
latter's jugular
using the short bone on its nose
backstage Sony encounters the figures
mistress who have become prey clear as
only with him and you two being forced
into servitude
she clearly admires sonny and asks that
she's scared which the protagonist
replies all the time but that hate is
her driving force that keeps her alive
sonny is seduced by the girl before
being stabbed through the head this is
some Lady Deathstrike level of attack
and wilds faker steps forward and tries
to kill her through using his mistress
to stamp on her head we learn that sonny
is in fact a beast within a beast and on
the night that she was right she
actually was killed and with the help of
her allies bonded back to her body was
her mind was put into a machine that is
able to enact revenge who the same link
up that is used on the beasts overall
it's an amazing twist in the tale and
one that comes really left field to let
you know when someone has hate in their
heart nothing can stop them sure it's a
nihilistic look at the world but it's
also fantastic and it instantly pits the
tone of the series perfectly making for
a gory messed-up yet wholly satisfying
send-off and now on to my review
anthologies have always been pretty hit
and miss for me but I've always enjoyed
them overall and loved death and robots
is no different whether it's the anime
Rick's Batman the Gotham Knight and more
there's always some classic episodes
hidden in the run and whilst love death
and robots has a couple of duds in there
the good still outweighs the bad David
Fincher and Tim Miller have done an
outstanding job of creating a varied
amount of tales that perfectly mix
comedy drama action and horror into a
package that feels like the kind of
thing that Netflix built for while it's
not every episode will be for everyone
and there will be an episode for
everyone in there whether you like
sci-fi action horror or just animation
you will be spellbound by the series and
I'm even thinking about binge watching
it again because it's that good overall
I had a phenomenal time with love death
and robots and highly recommend that you
take time out this weekend to give it a
watch obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show and if there are
any episodes in there that you want me
to cover make sure you leave them in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it make sure you
check out my breakdown of this week's
other big Netflix release triple
frontier which would be linked at the
end
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]